[Music]
oh my God
all right
you know how I judge a presidential
candidate I assess his persuasiveness
his intellect his backstory but even
more it boils down to one thing does my
dog like him
which means it's time for
if you want to get to Pennsylvania
Avenue you've got to give this dog his
do this is the gust test
yep starting now I'm challenging anyone
running for president to come on this
show and let me interview them while
they hold my dog Gus so let's bring him
out
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah hold on to him Vivek
there you go there you go he well he
wants he wants so badly to get away from
you this is not a good sign this is not
a good sign oh he wants Jamie to be
president he wants Jamie
uh not me neither oh he wants Greg he
wants what's wrong little guy oh my God
the president there you go
all right Vivek last week you were
interviewed by CNN's knucklehead in
Chief Don Lemon and now the New York
Times says that interview led to Lemon
being fired let's watch that tape the
lessons that we aren't allowed to enjoy
the freedoms I disagree with you on that
Don I disagree with you I think you're
doing a disservice to our country by
failing to recognize
and you live in this country then you
can disagree with me well here's where
you and I have a different point of view
I think we should be able to express our
views regardless of the color of our
skin we should have this debate without
me regarding you as a black man
insulting that you're regarding you as a
fellow citizen here whatever ethnicity
you are explaining to me what it's like
to be black whatever ethnicity I'll tell
you what I am I'm an Indian American I'm
proud of it but I think we should have
this debate black white doesn't matter
oh he took that so personally and then
he got fired he did
what do you uh I bought some uh
let me give you give you some lemons you
make some lemonade there you go there
you go you got your silly little junk in
all right now Jamie give them back over
there you've got you've got to get there
come on Gus come on Gus let's get over
here oh there you go so um
what do you think about what what's your
plan when you debate Trump yeah look I'm
just gonna call it like it is yeah you
had you had a chance to do what you were
gonna do and we'll let the I'm gonna I'm
gonna let Gus out on the stage yes
and and you know I'm gonna give him
credit for what he did yeah you know he
he took the country America First agenda
as far as he was going to take it we're
going to take it to the next level and
you know what I tell people is Greg's
America First doesn't belong to Donald
Trump yeah it doesn't belong to me it
belongs to the people of this country
exactly we remember that it was
no nobody owns out what would you do
about crime when it's such a city
problem and no one's really done
anything well I think snacks for him oh
he's got oh he found him he found him
found the snacks he has to hide the
snacks around your body that's what I do
you know so here's here's the funny
thing is my wife and I actually have a
deal yeah I'll be honest with you I'm
not the dog person in the family she's
been wanting to get a dog I vetoed it
but she said that if you make me move to
Washington DC to the White House we're
getting a dog so I think the chances are
we're gonna get a friend she now if
you're successful there's a lot of dogs
in DC you know what I'm saying
some of them in the White House am I
right yeah one of them now so uh what
what do you think is the biggest problem
facing America I think we're in the
middle of a national identity crisis we
ask most people my age really any age
what it means to be American today you
get a blank stare in response yeah
that's a problem they've replaced
patriotism with identity they did
everybody's into who or what they are
and not what they belong to right race
gender sexuality climate I think we can
revive the individual yeah family the
nation God four-letter words you're not
supposed to say
well it's become a four-letter word yes
yeah yeah that's how we treat it yeah
that's how we treat it anyway yeah there
he goes God's fake you know you don't
you're not going to have a chance with
Gus Gus's Gus is wrestlers here I like
it Gus got energy yeah I hope he doesn't
get electrocuted uh
that'll be three dogs in one month oh no
so
how would you deal with the fentanyl
crisis I believe I know that you were
like you've got a pretty aggressive
stance yeah look I think that we
shouldn't apologize for this we have a
problem on the southern border Chinese
manufactured fentanyl coming from I'm
not even kidding this Wuhan it's coming
all the way over here yeah yeah yeah so
I put the military on the border and I
would use our military to annihilate the
drug cartels I don't know why that's a
problem if you've done that with like
terrorists kind of thing Bin Laden
soleimani if we can do it over there we
can do it to the drug cartel south of
our own border Gus what do you think
about that do you think that that's the
solution for our Terror our drug problem
we're going to let the dogs out on them
nicely done now I see that what about
um immigration you notice that you see
mayor Adams now suddenly sounding like
Donald Trump now that he has to come
face to face with being a sanctuary City
what would you do so I again I believe
use our military to secure our own
border if we can use it to secure
somebody else's border halfway around
the world we can use it to secure our
own Southern border so it's not just
building the wall
it's securing the wall with our actual
military and that's that's my with Trump
on the debate stage that's what I would
say is great ideas now let's actually
take it one step further and get the job
done which we can do if we're doing it
based on first principles and moral
Authority not just Vengeance and
grievance and that's why I want to go
further with that America First can you
elaborate on the phrase first principles
I always hear that and I always pretend
like I know what it means it means like
gravity well it's like the base yeah the
basic ideas that set the nation into
motion yeah Merit is a principle free
speech is a principle rule of law we
were about to talk about basic principle
the idea we're talking about this with
Biden the people who we elect to run the
government
ought to be the ones who actually run
the government not this managerial
bureaucracy that runs the show those are
basic American principles I think the
last President we had that tied his
policies to actual principle the why was
Ronald Reagan I think we have missed
that in this country for a long time I'm
the first Millennial actually running
U.S president ever as a Republican and
I'm doing it as a member of my
generation I'm tying this to the Y for
that's amazing yeah that's amazing
because it's almost like the Millennials
just got skipped right you know on
everything they kind of got screwed Joe
are you a Millennial Generation X but we
didn't do much better yeah
yeah awesome and Biden's over twice my
age and then some but it's not just an
age thing it's an ability to channel
this to young people in this country and
that's what I'm trying to do in the race
well I think I think Gus's uh Gus is
giving you a thumbs up or yes guys Craft
on my shirt
Gus what do you think any questions I
think he's good all right
no way
thank you for that good sport on our day
that was fun that was fun
he was great yeah it was great our
inaugural dog segments hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else